since your background is national
security and foreign policy
uh what what's going on right now with
palestine between hamas and israel okay
obviously we've seen it we've seen the
videos we've seen the stories we've seen
one say if they want to come against us
we're gonna go we saw what
ben netanyahu responded with and it
keeps happening there were more events
that took place today it's still ongoing
how ugly can this get or do you think
this is gonna calm down and it's gonna
be the traditional war that they keep
having you know every few years you
think this can get ugly or you think
it's going to calm down
no i think i think i think the trump
administration basically looked at this
and said look we're not going to let the
palestinians get in the way of middle
east peace anymore in fact they're out
of the equation we're going to go after
whatever peace we can
we can achieve and i think what's
happened is
the palestinians see in the bible
administration an ability to basically
tie
peace in the middle east to solving the
palestinian issue
and that's an issue that you know from
my perspective i don't think palace
the palestinians want to solve yes
arafat had the opportunity to solve this
and basically decided not to he thought
that he could make more money
by continuing to be you know prevent
that from happening so
i think the palestinians think they have
an opportunity to basically
go back and and relitigate this again
and i think you know
the trump administration was really
achieving in the in the last part of the
administration was really
achieving some goals because they said
look we can't solve the palestinian we
can't basically solve all of middle east
peace and by saying hey we have to solve
the palestinian issue first
no let's start let's start going after
those low-hanging fruit
anybody knows that if you're trying to
solve the hardest problem first
you're and you're making everything else
contingent on that
that you're going to be you're bound for
failure and i think that the palestinian
sense that and i think that's what
they're um that's why they're doing this
what's the what's the right move to make
today for us what is the right move in
the u.s to make now obviously we're not
a trump administration we're a bitemen
administration it's a different one what
is the right move for america to make
that we're watching this taking place
they're going back and forth
it doesn't seem like it's slowing down
obviously you know we know
uh historically israel has got one of
the strongest air forces i know
everybody knows how powerful
their hamas is you know they're uh
what is it assad is their secret you
know the intelligence they gathered
they're one of the best in in the
around the world but what role should
america play in this
well i don't know there is a role for
america to play in this i think
one role we shouldn't play is to
basically say
um when the israelis respond to attacks
and provocations to say
hey guys cut it out you know don't stop
stop you know responding to the
provocations and attacks
i think quite frankly it let let the
israeli settle it and
don't in any way
support or give any kind of credence to
or or support for what the palestinians
are doing i think
that's what they're hoping to see they
want to they want to see something
any kind of sliver of sign under the
body administration that would give them
indication that
they're going to come down on israel um
to to prevent them from
responding to their profit provocations
and attacks i saw earlier today biden
talked about the fact
that they're going to stay out of their
way and kind of try to let them hash it
out which i think you probably agree
with that decision
but you're seeing a lot of people on the
news that are saying things like i heard
a story
from trevor noah he was explaining this
whole thing and he says okay i don't
know i know people going to get upset
but
when i was a kid and i was growing up
you know
my i would fight with my brother and
sister and one time my younger brother
hit me and i hit him back and my mom
said why would you hit somebody that you
know they can't hurt you
why hurt somebody that you know they
even though they hit you first
there is this fantasy of
hey i know they're bombing us but we
know you can destroy them
just let it go just let it go
why is it so important for netanyahu to
not just look the other way
instead to retaliate what what is the
downside of him not retaliating versus
him retaliating
i think if you don't retaliate if you
don't um deal with the the attacks and
the provocations and you invite more
it's it's it's it happens all the time
did you say you invite more you invite
more you invite more attacks
now all of a sudden you've got the the
lebanese
um coming in and joining in and maybe
even the syrians you know
you have to it's it's really you know
one of the things i remember about the
the the trump administration i was
actually at mar-a-lago
um it was back at the hotel and i knew
that she
was having dinner with the president
and then i saw the strikes happening in
syria
so the the strikes happening in syria
were twofold one was to
basically deal with the use of chemical
weapons but also to tell she
that you know hey i'm i mean business so
in a lot of ways you have to basically
meet provocation with strength or else
you're inviting more attacks
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye